hey guys welcome back to brand-new me to
Rebecca I'm Monster Hunter world again
and today our contemporary Ostra has
just released into the game so we're
gonna do one of my usual solo guides go
over some of the things that he usually
has in his moveset some of the new
things as well talk about them tips
moveset loadout physiology report and
stuff like that so as always let's get
started with today's video
so first the quest is going to be under
the event tab but it's gonna call it be
called the scorn of the Sun it's an HR
50 quest and its star 9 quest as well
there are a few changes like a more
darker skin tone and armor color
compared to the normal Telstra and AAT
crucial a turf war which is pretty damn
cool as well but we'll get into that a
little bit later but for the physiology
report as always just rose head wing and
tail are his weak points but those exact
three points being breakable or
separable for max damage you want to
always be hitting the forehead since it
is the weakest and does the most damage
for in terms of elements and ailments he
is weakest to ice and water and poison
and stun for the ailments it is the most
useful and you want to be using that a
lot throughout the fight well you can
use the dragon weapon to negate his
Blasket or as fire skin because of the
elder sailor comes with it I don't think
it's as effective as a water or ice
elemental weapons to keep that in mind
for loadouts you want to be using the
flash pods for when he's in the air cool
drinks for the lava rooms temporal
Rocksteady or fireproof mental will do I
do prefer the fireproof man to over the
Rocksteady though just in case you would
like to know and the usual max ancient
mega potions as well as demon drugs
armor skins and life powders the first
move is going to be this simple pounce
attack it's one of the basic moves
basically simply running sideways from
him if you're facing him or Superman
jumping will dodge of this move he loves
to also use this charge and swing move
as well an issue with it is since these
are temperatures creep damage and goes
through the temporal mental so Superman
jumping helps tremendously with this
move as well next is going to be his
spray tech it can be blessed or fired
depending on what's the surrounding of
his body no storm left to right and then
back again if you're facing him hiding
his armpits you can both avoid the move
and do damage to his head if you are far
away simply Superman jump at the correct
time to dodge the entire move or run out
of the range of it but that's usually
unlikely for that to happen next move is
the fire blaster steps on his hind legs
and blows a huge ball of fire on the
target that appears on the ground
running away either to the left or right
if it can help dodge the move but if
you're caught Superman jump to avoid
this devastating move if you're quick
enough you can also run forwards during
that movie
underneath the stomach when he does this
and getting some free damage while he
charges this up and as well he has a
supernova bomb which is obviously one of
his older moves he would go into the air
exploding doing crazy damage to the area
around him
you can either flash plot him during the
attack run away from his range or if
you're cocky you could stand right
underneath him and Superman jump at the
perfect time because when after this
movie is done he likes to float casually
back down to the ground which can give
you some free hits depending on the
weapon you use and then the last one is
going to be the strafe run he will
either be breathing fire in an arc
pattern and then die problem the player
or just I've done the player all in
general you can also flash bought him at
this move as well simpler to the
supernova bomb or just watch him and
dodge roll out of the way once he
completes this move for some general
tips there's an arc attempt or coup
shala and an arc attempt for territory
which was really cool to watch but the
sadly after though arc tempered crucial
leaves the location because we're
beginning we're gonna be getting him in
a couple weeks so we get to defeat him
eventually soon but it's actually really
helpful because goshala does crazy
damage while also taking some heavy
damage himself during this fight which
can of course lower his health and make
this fight just a little bit easier in
the crystal room I like the cult there's
gonna be two big crystals that you can
use to break on him I used one I was
going to use the second one but sadly he
ran away when I went to do it and I
didn't get the damage for it but you can
use both of them and do some crazy
damage with that and there's also going
to be a lava volcano type of water
fountain thing in the one lava pit room
that you can actually let him go through
so if you try to kite him into that it
can also do some minor damage as well to
help you out during the fight like I
said before you want to be using flash
pods on the sweep attack strafe run or
the supernova bomb to either cancel it
and get some knockout damage or anything
like that if you're struggling with
those moves and then for the last tip
watch out for the blast sparks because
those will be doing some hefty damage
and if you happen to have the blast of
life on you all simply roll three times
and it will get rid of the effect if the
sparks are on they're gone you either
make them explode instantly or after the
move is complete he will explode them on
his own so definitely watch out for that
if I missed the tipper strategy use let
me know in the comments below so
everyone can be caught up to date on how
to defeat arc tempered tea Ostra solo as
best as possible
oh yeah guys it's going to be the end of
the video today toaster honestly it
wasn't really that bad of a boss I would
say he's one of the easier arc tempered
monsters we've gotten so far compared to
Kirin and vowels lock I like I said I
say I think he's going to be one of the
easiest ones personally he wasn't too
hard of a fight to defeat guy's going to
be the end of the video - hope you guys
did enjoy lichte V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I cover the solo
guides of all the mods
in months to run a world on top of that
I also make tips and tricks to make
everybody a better monster hundred
player on all that good stuff as well my
two most recent videos would be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out with that guys hope ever great
yesterday thank for watching the video
and peace out
[Music]